non-minimalists
is there any area in life where you
allow for more
rather than less now i'm going to give
this to you i'm just going to tee it up
with my pithy answer and you tell me
what you think this is
an excerpt from i believe it's somewhere
one of our essays
minimalists don't focus on having less
less
less they focus on making room for more
more time more passion more creativity
more experiences more contribution more
contentment more freedom clearing the
clutter creates room for the intangibles
that make life more rewarding and so
i really think minimalism is in many
ways about more right
we often think of a as this this vector
for less
and that's true but but it's what are we
going to fill our life with after that
right
yeah i agree i think i think minimalism
is not living without to live with
everything you need
and i think when we step back and read
that podcast
yeah that's great when we step back and
ignore the less or more
statements in this and look at the word
enough then it becomes about us
so what is enough for you it's not about
how much do i consume of this or how
less do i consume of that
is how much do i consume that becomes
enough for me so i think if he ignores
the his question of what what do you get
more of
in life i think just look at what would
be enough for me
in my situation in my life then i think
he's going to find the answer he's
looking for so for me
i don't i don't get more of anything i
just get enough of everything i want um
changes over time right so so as your
preferences change maybe your interests
change your hobbies change
your desires change um
even our impulses will change and so we
become different people over time not
radically different necessarily but 10
years from now you're going to be
different from how you are today and so
identifying what is enough what is
enough today could be too much tomorrow
so we have to be willing to let go a day
from now a week from now a month from
now a year from now
and i think that's why it's this sort of
continual process you don't get there to
worry all right i've got enough
and now life is perpetually perfect it
doesn't work that way
and i think i think another thing i want
to say is to add to that i kind of look
up to look at decluttering
instead of going approaching it from a
perspective of okay i'm going to
declutter today
and then wait a week i'm going to have
another massive declutter a week from
now
i kind of look at it from the
perspective of decluttering as i live so
anytime i come across an object or a
thought
or a digital thing that i no longer need
or find value in
i deal with it in that moment so if it's
a thought i figure okay why am i having
this negative thought or this positive
thought
and how can i approach it or how can i
get rid of it if i come across a piece a
shirt or or some jeans that i no longer
wear
it goes right into a basketball front
door and then it goes to goodwill at the
end of the week so
i think if you look at a perspective to
clutter and as you live and another
thing i want to say
is when you think about the idea of more
um i always say in my content that you
know different phases in life require
different things and necessities
so just like you said things are going
to change it's always going to be fluid
and so you have to be able to change
with life and you know i'm thinking
through some of the pieces that i say in
my content i always try to
entwine poetry somehow and i say that
change is going to happen regardless if
you're ready to it or not it just
depends on how you move
with it determines how it's going to
happen in your life yeah so if you're
rigid in your life
change is going to happen no matter
around you so then you're going to feel
the the effects of that yeah but if
you're fluid with it
and when change happens and you're
moving been with it and adapt as just as
you're supposed to yeah
i think one of the biggest mistakes i've
seen people make with minimalism is they
look at it as a destination
we get questions a lot we're like oh
i've got rid of everything now what
and now i'm not happy right now i'm not
happy like now it's like that's the same
thing as i bought the thing why am i not
happy
thinking the the accomplishment the task
the completion and i get it especially
people like me i'm a bit of a completist
by nature
but also realizing that like that
destination is not going to make you
happy
when i write a book it's not the
publication that makes me happy it's the
joy of the process
ryan and i have spent the last two and a
half years on
this next book that we're working on
called love people use things and
and you have to remember to stop and
enjoy that because when the book comes
out it's great that people get value
from it but the real joy comes from
from the actual creation of the thing
right yeah and i like what you said how
people look at minimalism as in the end
thing
and i like to say that minimalism is a
tool not the end result yeah so you
think about life you think about
building a house you have to lay the
foundation first and the foundation
comes from
our emotions and our mindset so dealing
with those things and then we add
minimalism to the mix
it's just a tool to help you build your
life it's not the end goal so that's why
it looks different for everyone
yeah so your tool could be a hammer your
tool could be a chainsaw mine could be a
screwdriver
just depends on how we make those tweaks
to our life using the tool of minimalism
yeah
absolutely
you